herzlich willkommen ich weiß nicht wie
es ihnen geht aber in mir regt sich so
etwas wie vorfreude
viele länder haben angekündigt die
massnahmen des lockdown schrittweise zu
lockern
wir blicken langsam also wieder in die
zukunft mit der neuen aussicht mehren
sich aber auch die fragen ob sich unser
leben unsere gesellschaft unser
wirtschaften nachhaltig verändert haben
über die ära nach gruner spreche ich
heute mit zwei der führenden
intellektuellen unserer zeit und zwar
etwas später in der sendung mit der
philosophie in tallinn ehmke
die für die süddeutsche zeitung ein
crooner tagebuch schreibt zuerst aber
ist uns harald welt satt zugeschaltet er
ist soziologie und sozialpsychologie
professor für transformations- design an
der universität flensburg und leiter der
stiftung kultur 2 herzlich willkommen
herr welt sein
daher werde in dieser zeit kann man
wahrscheinlich gar nicht anders als
zuerst zu fragen was sie wahrscheinlich
schon viele journalisten gefragt haben
nämlich wie geht es ihnen eigentlich mir
selber geht es total gut für mich ist ja
die lebens veränderung auch nicht so
gravierend wenn ich sowieso
schreibtischtäter binden und so was wie
home office für mich eigentlich eher ein
normaler zustand ist es für die meisten
anderen menschen insofern mein leben
eigentlich in ordnung
sie befassen sich ja von berufs wegen
mit der transformation von
gesellschaften das ist einer der
schwerpunkte der sich schon lange auch
in ihrer forschen umtreibt nun klingt ja
transformation nach etwas langsamen noch
etwas durchdachten die korona pandemie
ist aber eher so was fast schon wie ein
erdrutsch naja es ist halt eine geradezu
unfassbar beschleunigte veränderung von
gesellschaft sehr praktisch von jetzt
auf gleich ohne irgendeinen bremsweg
runterfahren der öffentlichen
aktivitäten runterfahren vieler bereiche
der wirtschaft runterfahren der
kulturellen aktivitäten der sozialen
beziehungen
sofern sie über den engsten kreis hinaus
gehen und so weiter das heißt als
sozialpsychologe würde ich sagen wir
haben eine gigantische versuchsanordnung
und es ist sehr interessante anzugucken
wie wirken sich diese veränderung jetzt
gegenwärtig eigentlich aus gibt es denn
eigentlich jetzt aus ihrer sicht
irgendwelche resultate dazu wie sich
gesellschaften nachhaltige verändernden
sie dass er wenn ich langsam von statten
geht oder wenn eine krise uns ganz
plötzlich zwingt zum umdenken
also ich glaube und das hat mal der
soziologe karl otto hondrich vor vielen
jahren gesagt er ist inzwischen
verstorben
dass gesellschaften eigentlich nur
wieder wählen lernen das heißt durch
ereignisse mit denen sie konfrontiert
sind im normalfall auf lernen
gesellschaften nicht da modifizieren sie
vielleicht eins in einem kleinen
teilbereich aber gesellschaften haben
eigentlich eine große trägheit wenn sie
gut funktionieren dann sind sie darauf
bedacht dass sie weiterhin gut
funktionieren und das ist natürlich wie
wir wissen für viele wünschenswerte
transformationsprozesse wahnsinnig
hinderlich also sie reaktionen anpassung
an den klimawandel
verändertes verhalten was ressourcen
angeht und so weiter es ist unglaublich
träge da gibt es wahnsinnig viele
blockierungen aber in solchen
krisensituationen plötzlich dinge sehr
sehr schnell möglich die unter
normalbedingungen überhaupt nicht
möglich werden wobei das jetzt noch
nicht heißt es nichts darüber aussagt ob
das positiv oder negativ
ja das wollte ich natürlich jetzt gerade
fragen gleich können sie dazu doch nach
farben naja ich finde es ein bisschen
fragwürdig ehrlich gesagt es gab ja
sofort nach den nehmen nachdem shutdown
stimmen um mal ganz begeistert gewesen
ist jetzt sehen wir eine entschleunigung
der flugverkehr staub so jetzt haben wir
die welt wie wir sie eigentlich
hinterher haben
ich finde das fragwürdig deswegen weil
natürlich von der dauer der krise es
abhängig ist was die folgen sein
ob man gewissermaßen sortier vorgang
machen kann man sagen kann wir haben
jetzt verschiedene dinge in dieser
merkwürdigen auszeit
zur kenntnis genommen wir nehmen zur
kenntnis lieferketten sind ein großes
problem globalisierung ist entzaubert es
geht auch alles viel langsamer
die welt reichweite muss nicht so groß
sein gibt viele verschiedene faktoren
die jetzt sagen wir mal für eine
wünschenswerte ökosoziale transformation
nutzbar sein werden
wenn aber dieser zustand lange andauert
dann werden natürlich die
wirtschaftlichen und die psychosozialen
folgen so gravierend dass die menschen
nur denken um gottes willen wir wollen
aus den zustand wieder haus koste es was
es wolle komme was da wolle
wir wollen irgendeine form von sozialer
normalität wieder haben und dann wird
die folge sein dass alle diese gibt ja
jetzt schon den begriff green recovery
als man kommt sozusagen mit ökologischen
strategien am besten aus der krise raus
aber diese fragen werden dann
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht gestellt
sondern dann wird es darum gehen
irgendwie so schnell wie möglich wieder
auf die beine zu kommen und alles andere
kann man dann später machen sie haben ja
vor noch gar nicht langer zeit dieses
buch geschrieben alles könnte anders
sein und darin zitieren sie ja
eigentlich die transformation einer
gesellschaft aber eben durchdacht mit
demokratischen mitteln langsam
vonstatten gehen aber da geht es
eigentlich genau um eine welt mit
weniger konsum weniger mobilität
sozialverträgliches wirtschaften haben
sie beim schreiben dieses buches ich
muss so fahren in welchen zeiträumen
haben sie gedacht war ihnen je irgendwie
vor augen dass etwas passieren könnte
auf diese fragen so dermaßen schnell
aufs tapet bringen wird sie schmunzeln
schauen ja ja ja natürlich beendet
werden irgend jemand behaupten würde er
habe mit so etwas gerechnet dann kann
man das gar nicht ernst nehmen niemand
hat damit gerechnet was übrigens
historisch interessant ist weil wir
überhaupt keine tiefgreifende krise kein
epochen ereignis haben was irgendjemand
vorhergesehen hat also weder aus der
geschichtswissenschaft noch aus der
soziologie noch aus der
politikwissenschaft alle stehen sie oder
aus der wirtschaftswissenschaft alle
stehen sie dann immer da und sagen
das ist jetzt passiert ist es für sich
genommen schon mal interessant weil wir
daran sehen können dass agnostischen
möglichkeiten doch ausgesprochen
begrenzt sind diesen immer ausgerichtet
auf den normalfall auch so und die
veränderungsprozesse die in diesem buch
skizziere die haben ganz
unterschiedliche zeithorizont da sind
einige dabei wo ich sagen würde das kann
man ganz direkt einführen also wie jetzt
zum beispiel es ist ja es steht jetzt in
dem buch nicht drin aber sagen wir mal
bestimmte eskapistische form des
tourismus abzuschaffen wie kreuzfahrten
und sowas das haben wir jetzt
gewissermaßen im zeitraffer schon
erledigt durch diese krise die frage der
autofreien stadt
solche dinge sind dinge die kann man
relativ zeitnah angehen aber in dem buch
geht es ja auch um konkrete utopien im
sinne eines anderen sozial- verhaltens-
oder der des verschwindens von grenzen
und so was und das ist in einem buch
skizziert als ein sehr viel
längerfristiger horizont und ja ich habe
deswegen geschmunzelt weil die große
frage stellung für die transformation
ist ja geschieht sie bei design und bei
desaster
also sozusagen gestalten oder reagieren
und jetzt haben wir ja tatsächlich die
situation des desasters und eine eine
wirklich im in höchstgeschwindigkeit
ablaufen der transformation aber mit
total offenem ausgang
wenn wir wissen ja überhaupt nicht
gekommen denn diese gesellschaften
wieder raus aus diesem diesem geschehen
ist von dem der gerade ein teil sind und
wenn sie dieses stichwort der termin bei
design oder bei dieser ist dann gehört
war ja auch dazu dass bei design zb auch
heißen könnte dass wir das als freie
menschen tun
und tatsächlich hat ihr buch ja auch
einen untertitel nämlich eine
gesellschaft utopie für freie menschen
und was wir jetzt ja gerade sehen ist
eigentlich eine gesellschaft utopie für
unfreie menschen respektive werden ganz
viele menschen im moment in einem
zustand hineingezwungen zu dem sie nicht
auf haben konnten und den sie eigentlich
auch wenn man sie fragt tiefer abscheu
ja aber auch das ist natürlich eine
frage der dauer dieser dieser krise also
ich glaube dass man jetzt
in demokratischen gesellschaften in der
bundesrepublik in der schweiz in
österreich und so weiter als bürgerinnen
und bürger einwilligt in die
beschränkung der grundrechte dann
geschieht es ja nur so zu sagen wenn wir
den referenzrahmen haben es herrscht
krise es herrscht eine epidemiologische
notwendigkeit das jetzt auf sich zu
nehmen und es ist aber immer sozusagen
im bewusstsein so das ist ein
vorübergehende zustand und danach werden
wir wieder unsere gewohnten freiheiten
haben und hier kommen wir natürlich ein
gebiet das relativ schwierig werden
könnte wenn nämlich diese grundrechts
beschränkungen auf längere sicht
eingehalten werden oder den leuten
auferlegt werden wir kommen auch dort in
schwierige situationen wo dann handy
tracking als etwas sozusagen sozial
erwünschtes plötzlich verstanden wird
und wir entwicklung haben wo plötzlich
etwas eingeführt wird was man hinterher
gar nicht so schlecht gar nicht so
leicht wieder aus der gesellschaft
rauskriegt besonders dann wenn es sich
als erfolgreich in der solchen
bekämpfung oder wir haben noch
verschärfter natürlich situation in
ländern wie ungarn beispielsweise oder
anderen ländern wo die krise genutzt
wird um grundrechte dauerhaft forever
auszuhebeln und die gesellschaft als
ganze zu verwandeln das sind alles
dimensionen innerhalb dieser krise wo
zum gegebenen zeitpunkt ist extrem
schwer ist zu sagen wie sind denn da die
weiteren entwicklungen also wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe dann sagen sie wir
müssen einerseits vor dem auch warnen
was sie in anderen büchern zum teil auch
eine konsens verschiebung nennen also
dass wir plötzlich merken sachen werden
akzeptabel die wir vorher ganz klar
zurückgewiesen haben
wir müssen erklärt seien in beschreiben
dieser konsens verschiebungen und
zugleich brauchen wir ja aber schon auch
die momente in denen sich der konsens
verschiebt nur der sollte sich eben
transformieren langsam und demokratisch
abgestützt verstehe ich das richtig
ich würde so gerne verschärfen ich würde
wir sehen ja jetzt in den europäischen
ländern eine eine unglaubliche
rationalität auf seiten der bevölkerung
wir haben ja noch an keiner stelle auch
in den ländern wo die regeln viel
schärfer sind also in spanien
beispielsweise jetzt wirklich massiven
protest oder einfach sozusagen das
ignorieren dieser beschlossenen
maßnahmen gesehen
es gibt ja sozusagen eine ganz hohe
übereinstimmung der auf der ebene der
einsicht der bürgerinnen und der bürger
mit dem handeln was anscheinend
notwendig ist und ich finde das muss man
auch von seiten der regierungen würdigen
wir haben jetzt in dem sinn ich habe
vorhin gesagt wir haben eine
versuchsanordnung und die
versuchsanordnung zeigt uns dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger in einer wirklich
absolut überwiegende mehrheit in der
lage sind erstens selbst zu denken
zweitens sich selbst zu beschränken wenn
ihnen ihre überlegungen das nahelegen
und drittens sich auch wenn das noch gar
nicht kodifizierte regeln sind sich so
zu verhalten dass ist für die
bewältigung einer solchen pandemie
absolut sinnvoll ist und ich finde das
ist eine lernerfahrung die auch von
seiten der politik und von seiten
anderer eliten zur kenntnis genommen
wird man hat hier eine hohe
verlässlichkeit auf seiten der
bürgerschaft und das muss man auch für
jetzt diese diskussion um weitere
lockerungen und sowas zur kenntnis
nehmen ich reg mich im moment gerade ein
bisschen darüber auch dass je länger
diese diese ausnahme situation anhält
desto paternalistische wird das
selbstverständnis auf seiten der politik
und desto infantilisierung kommt man
sich als bürger vor obwohl man doch
jetzt eigentlich die ganze zeit sehr
compliant also sozusagen ein verständig
rational sich verhalten hat und da muss
politik auch nach steuern in ihrem
selbstverständnis der welt aber was
macht sie so sicher dass sie einem so
sagen die jetzt mal positiven
optimistischen bild des menschen jetzt
gerade anhängen ich mein man könnte ja
auch sagen das ist nicht so dass die
leute jetzt rational agieren dass die
sich überlegt haben ist es nicht
vernünftig diesen regeln zu gehorchen
auch in das jetzt diesen lockt sondern
viele sagen auch na ja das wurde uns
einfach angedroht und einige sind auch
der meinung wir sollten auch daraus
etwas lernen wenn wir auf den
klimawandel blicken war immer eindeutig
gewisse regeln können hier nicht
durchsetzen das volk wird das nie
mittragen und jetzt sehen wir das geht
ja doch wir können regeln durchsetzen
aber zugleich natürlich gewarnt dass ihr
plötzlich hätten ihm zuständen sind wie
in china wo ein staatsapparat diktiert
wo es lang geht also zusammengefasst
nicht interessiert warum glauben sie
dass die menschen das wirklich im
innersten mittragen und nicht einfach
nur aus angst vor sanktionen die regeln
befolgen
weil sie es einfach tun ich meine jeder
jede bewegung im öffentlichen raum jetzt
zur zeit wenn man einkaufen geht oder
bisschen sport macht oder sowas zeigt ja
dass die leute sich genauso auch
verhalten also das bedürfnis nach regel
übertretungen ist wesentlich geringer
als beispielsweise im straßenverkehr
also und wenn man interviews macht oder
er sich mit leuten unterhält oder auch
interviews sich anhört dann gibt es
immer sofort bevor man sagt was einen
stört die betonung dessen das sei ja nun
mal jetzt notwendig also insofern glaube
ich und das ist muss man zur kenntnis
nehmen dass wir in dem sinne sehr sehr
starke demokratien wohnen dass leute
wirklich aktiv teilnehmen an solchen
solchen außergewöhnlichen geschehnissen
und ihrer bewältigung und dann muss man
dazu sagen wenn wir dann noch die ganzen
initiativen uns anschauen also bis dann
sozusagen aktionen der hilfe für
obdachlose oder für ältere bevölkerung
mitglieder oder im kulturbereich
konzerte und all diese dinge gibt dann
muss man doch wirklich mal die
perspektive umdrehen und sagen wir sind
doch jede nicht in einer monarchie wo
irgendwie könige dekretieren wie das
verhalten zu sein hat sondern wir sind
in aufgeklärten demokratien wo man
zutrauen in die bevölkerung haben kann
und übrigens umgekehrt dass er auch
gespielt weil das system vertrauen also
in die regierung gegenwärtig eher höher
ist als unter normalbedingungen ich
finde da muss ein verhältnis der
angemessenheit auch von seiten der
politik wiederhergestellt
jetzt haben sie bereits folien im
gespräch erwähnt dass es diese
diskussion gibt um das trucking also um
die frage ob wir die smartphones
einsetzen sollen wenn ich jetzt warum
geht auch schrittweise aus diesem block
darum zu finden und tatsächlich hat die
schweiz entschieden am elften mal eine
entsprechende ab zur verfügung zu
stellen es ist eine aktiv an der eth und
dfl entwickelt worden ist es eine ab die
der central laufen wir das heißt die
privaten daten werden auf den
smartphones verbleiben und es geht darum
dass via bluetooth die einzelnen handys
sich sozusagen finden und man alarmiert
wird wenn man gerne eines besitzers
eines handys war der später ein gibt es
dass er positiv getestet worden ist das
downloaden der abt wird freiwillig sein
nun haben sie ja auch ein buch
geschrieben die smarte diktatur
darin äußern sie sich sehr sagen wir mal
kritisch gegenüber die idee dass die
technik umsetzen wird
wie denken sie denn im moment über diese
vorstellung nach dass dieses tracking
ein wichtiges puzzleteil sein könnte
wenn es darum geht die maßnahmen zu
kommen
also ich persönlich finde das sehr
problematisch also bei ich der der weil
ich die befürchtung habe das in dem
augenblick wo das installiert wird
wer eine soziale innovation haben die
lautet unter bestimmten bedingungen ist
es wünschenswert und legitim
bewegungsdaten von bürgerinnen und
bürgern zu erheben und für bestimmte
zwecke zu nutzen
das ist dann sofort ja aber hier geht es
ja um was gut ist
er würde als argument kommen aber
gleichwohl ist es eigentlich etwas wo
die güterabwägung ob das in einer freien
gesellschaft überhaupt legitim sein kann
jemals die ist sozusagen schon mal hier
dann gestellt zweiter punkt den finde
ich wirklich wenn ich's neutral sagen
würde jetzt wahnsinnig interessant ist
ja der begriff der freiwilligkeit
den begriff der freiwilligkeit kann man
hier auch übersetzen in wünschenswerte
konformität und es wird ja definitiv so
sein dass menschen wenn menschen dann
nicht mitmachen sich diese app nicht
runterladen
die legitimation pflichtig sind und
gefragt werden warum machst du denn da
nicht mit und so formuliert dass unser
bundespräsident beispielsweise du
rettest doch menschen treten ja da wird
sozusagen das problem plötzlich
individualisiert und die freiwilligkeit
wird tatsächlich in einer art sozialen
zwang übersetzt dass derjenige
außenseiter ist der jetzt bei diesen
sachen nicht mitmacht und ich persönlich
frage mich das antiquierte
persönlichkeiten wie nicht ich habe gar
kein smartphone was passiert denn dann
mit mir bin ich sozusagen von vornherein
gesellschaftlicher außenseiter spielfeld
er aber sozial unverträglich oder was
ist das eigentlich und schon an zum
beispiel sieht man dass hier eine
konformität gewissermaßen installiert
der sich die menschen notwendigerweise
dann fügen muss also zum ersten punkt
diese erbliche jetzt vorgesehen ist wird
keine bewegungsprofile speichern das
läuft wirklich genau andersrum
aber der zweite punkt der ist
selbstverständlich gegeben es ist ja
nicht nur so dass personen die kein
smartphone besitzen oder welche ab nicht
herunterladen wollen vielleicht unter
druck geraten sondern es wurde auch
gezeigt dass jedes vierte smartphone
überhaupt nicht in der lage ist diese
spezifische technologie auszuführen weil
die geräte schlicht zu alt sind und die
frage ist natürlich ob man nicht genau
die gefährdeten menschen zum beispiel
auch ältere personen
daneben sich nicht schützen können mit
einem entsprechenden smartphone aber ich
würde vielleicht gerne noch einmal
diesen punkt der konformität auf
nebenher wälzer weil ja schon eine
bespannung besteht sagen jetzt mal ganz
grob gesagt wenn wir noch einmal
zurückkommen auf die eigentlich große
krise oder andere große krise unserer
zeit nämlich der clip den klimawandel
dann müssen wir ja doch sagen dass wir
uns ein stück weit eine neue konformität
doch wünschen die in diese richtung geht
dass menschen sich zb umweltfreundlicher
verhalten also wenn ein sozial druck
entsteht in die richtung dass nennen
weniger fliegen oder weniger auto fahren
oder glühbirnen einschrauben finden sie
diesen druck waren auch problematisch
ich würde es andersrum diskutieren wir
haben ja bislang kriegen die diskussion
um klimapolitik angucken haben wir einen
ganz umgekehrten druck da ist ja der
druck der der von der konsumgesellschaft
ausgeht wo den leuten ständig
konformität sozusagen angetragen wird
sie mögen bitte mehrfach im jahr urlaub
machen sie mögen bitte fernreisen machen
sie mögen bitte kreuzfahrten buchen und
sie mögen bitte größerer autos kaufen
und davon auch noch mehr
also wir haben ja eine andere kultur der
verschwendung oder der erhöhung von bild
reichweite wie hat mit rosa tous nennen
würde und damit er eine konformität in
genau gegenteilige richtung erzeugt und
diejenigen die die abweichler sind sind
dann die freude ist future oder leute
die sich vegan ernähren und so weiter
und wir haben ja genau das umgekehrte
dass diese menschen die versuchen in
irgendeiner weise auf die
herausforderung des klimawandels zu
reagieren die stehen ständig unter
rechtfertigungsdruck während die normale
verhältnisse sich die legitimieren
müssen obwohl die die eigentlich
zerstörerischen sind wenn wir das jetzt
auch die korona situation übertragen
würden dann wäre das eigentlich so
absurd dass alle diejenigen die jetzt
abstand halten oder eine maske tragen
oder zu hause bleiben oder so was dauert
begründen müssten deshalb sieht es tun
und diejenigen die korona partys feiern
das wären eigentlich diejenigen die
sozusagen denn normalbetrieb
präsentieren würden und daran kann man
sehen wie verquer eigentlich die ganze
diskussion und vor allen dingen auch die
politik in bezug auf den klimawandel
jetzt gibt es ja auch immer wieder die
stimmen die die ganze krise die korona
krise ein bisschen so gedeutet haben
dass die welt darauf irgendetwas
reagiert der deutsche bundestrainer jogi
löw hat zb gesagt na ja die welt die
erde die wehrt sich gerade erleben einen
kollektiven burnout der welt die erde
hat genug von unserem tempo von unserer
ausbeutung was halten sie von einer
moralisierung dieses
diese ganzen corona pandemie pandemie in
welcher art also moralisierung ist immer
kontraproduktiv mobilisierung erzeugt
immer das was psychologen reaktors und
menschen möchten nicht deshalb habe ich
vorhin auch diese paternalistische halte
von politik angesprochen menschen
möchten nicht moralisch zu etwas
gedrängt werden dann sagen sie nie ich
möchte das lieber selber bedenken und
entscheiden und thun häufig das genaue
gegenteil und jetzt die die korona krise
in gewisser weise zu romantisieren als
irgendetwas wo die welt jetzt zurück
schlägt oder der planet oder sonst was
das ist ja quatsch
also erstmal hätten wir ja unter anderen
bedingungen der globalen kommunikation
von dieser krise gar nichts mitgekriegt
oder auf ganz andere art und weise und
erleben ja gerade wie so eine solche im
unterschied zu der spanischen grippe
oder zu der pest oder sowas von modernen
gesellschaften mit modernen
kommunikationsmitteln ganz anders
geendet wird also irgendeine form von
von naturromantik hiermit einzuführen
scheint mir nicht besonders viel zu
bringen
wenn wir über transformation sprechen
und darüber was wir aus gesellschaft
gelernt haben werden dann ist eine große
frage auch wir umgehen mit den berufen
mit der bewertung von berufstätigkeiten
sie haben auch darauf hingewiesen dass
die pflegefachpersonen oft unterbezahlt
sind nicht die anerkennung kriegen die
sie eigentlich kriegen sollten
kommt dazu dass sehr viele menschen in
pflegenden berufen personen sind mit
migrationshintergrund und in
großbritannien ist gerade ein video wir
arge bauern mit dem hersteller qnap for
me now das ist eine art langes gedicht
zu blicken ganz kurz zusammen rein
ja herr welt glauben sie dass wir als
gesellschaft etwas lernen in der
bewertung von tätigkeiten und wird das
auch nachhaltig etwas bewirken im blick
auf das anerkennen was zum beispiel sehr
viele personen mit migrationshintergrund
bei günstiger arbeit machen
ja das ist so misst der
kaffeesatzleserei
natürlich haben wir im moment eine
wirksamkeit von solchen videos und wir
haben auch die sondern sagen sehr viel
krokodilstränen in talkshows wie toll
jetzt die leute sind die die die
gesellschaft zusammenhalten und so
weiter am ende wird es ganz hart darum
gehen um tarif auseinandersetzung um das
erkämpften von rechten und so weiter und
da würde man jetzt sagen klar ist die
optik auf die personengruppen die
tatsächlich für die gesellschaft extrem
relevant sind die hat sich verändert
also wir hatten nach der nach der
finanzkrise nachdem die sich verzogen
hat sind wir ja wir in modus
übergegangen banker und leute die sich
bonus genehmigen und so weiter für
systemrelevant zu halten
jetzt haben wir eine umgekehrte
perspektive und sehen wie die
gesellschaft aussehen würde wenn es eben
nicht diejenigen im supermarkt oder bei
der müllabfuhr wer sonst was gäbe aber
gesellschaften sind da natürlich
arrogant und in dem augenblick muss um
verteilung geht werden denn diese
argumente und erfahrung die dann in so
schönen videos oder beim abendlichen
klatschen und bedanken
das ist dann eben dann muss man mal
gucken was das dann wird es eher welcher
vielleicht zum schluss diejenigen die
dieses momentum dass diese krise ja doch
irgendwie auch ergibt oder wachruft
diejenigen die gerne eine welt möchten
wie sie sie eben skizzieren in diesem
alles könnte anders sein
wie nutzen sie dieses momentum was wäre
jetzt zu tun um zukunftsfähig zu sein
nach dieser krise also ich glaube dass
das wichtigste ist dass tatsächlich
auszuwerten was wir jetzt in der
gegenwart lernen
ich halte nicht viel davon
diskussionen darüber zu führen was wird
nach der krise sein weil wir das alle
nicht wissen und das von vielen faktoren
abhängt aber was wir im moment sehen und
werden wir verschiedene punkte schon
angesprochen
globalisierung ist entzaubert liberale
also sozusagen wirklich völlige markt
liberale wirtschaftspolitik ist
entzaubert wir sehen das auch daran dass
die ganzen ökonominnen und ökonomen ich
sag das jetzt mal einfach so überhaupt
nichts auch tasche haben
also wir haben uns über jahre angehört
dass der markt alles regelt und man
menschen nichts vorschreiben darf und
man sitzt auf anreize und so weiter in
dem augenblick vor die krise passiert
wird nach dem staat gerufen und das ist
der einzige programmpunkt was anderes
gibt es dann nicht wir müssen das
mitnehmen und sagen wir brauchen auch
eine andere form von
wirtschaftswissenschaften
wirtschaftswissenschaft die in der lage
sein muss gesellschaften und
finanzsysteme und markt systeme
resilienz zu machen das heißt auch unter
krisenbedingungen funktionsfähig zu
halten und nicht sozusagen nach einer
variable zustreben nämlich wachstum und
dann hört schon gewissermaßen die
theoriebildung auf und die praxis in
wiso und es sind jetzt lerneffekte
genauso wie die frage der bewertung von
tätigkeiten der wertschätzung von
gesellschaftlichen beiträgen und so
weiter und da würde ich sagen wir haben
das moment solche dinge jetzt
auszuwerten vor uns hin zu legen und zu
sagen was brauchen wir davon um eine
moderne nachhaltige gesellschaft unter
demokratischen bedingungen dann weiter
zu entwickeln
vielen herzlichen dank herr welt dass es
geht auch darum zu sehen was uns eben
fehlt um dann konstruktiv lösungen zu
entwickeln
vielen dank für dieses gespräch welt
sein und alles gute weiter im
home-office solange es noch nötig ist
danke sehr vielen dank ja wie es nach
der krise weitergehen wird wissen wir
nicht die philosophie ist auch nicht
zuständig für prognosen wohl aber dafür
darüber nachzudenken welche welt die
beste wäre und wie wir uns den besseren
annähern könnten über diese frage haben
nach schülerinnen und schüler
nachgedacht die bei unseren philosophie
wettbewerben mitgemacht haben einige
einsendungen haben uns corona
bedingt leider zu spät erreicht zum
beispiel die perfekte welt schachtel des
zehnjährigen fabrizio aus aeschi bei
spiez ich ihnen nicht vorenthalten will
das ist eine großartige schach die
beklebt mit ganz vielen bunten dingen
und vor allem bewohnt von
unterschiedlichsten menschen und tieren
und pflanzen die uns eine mitteilung
machen wollen wie die perfekte welt denn
auszusehen hat zb dieses einst wesen ein
winziges chamäleon das sagt auch die
kleinen haben was zu sagen oder dieser
punk hier
der sagt auch wenn man nicht die gleiche
sprache spricht versteht man sich
trotzdem oder auch eine person die hier
die sagt alle haben platz und weiß oder
schwarz
die welt ist nämlich farbig ja fabrizio
ich möchte mich ganz herzlich bedanken
für diese perfekte welt schachtel für
diese wunderbare arbeit
wir haben uns darüber wirklich sehr
gefreut ja und das nächste spreche ich
nun mit der philosophin und publizistin
carolin emcke sie war lange zeit als
kriegsreporterin tätig und hat in vielen
texten darüber nachgedacht wie über das
leiden eigentlich zu sprechen und zu
schreiben wäre aufgefallen ist mir ihre
kluge stehen wir jetzt wieder anlässlich
ihres kronach tagebuchs dass sie für die
süddeutsche zeitung schreibt dann siehst
du jetzt zugeschaltet ganz herzlich
willkommen parallel in dieser speziellen
zeit kann ich gar nicht anders als auch
sie zu fragen wie geht es ihnen denn so
ich vermute in manchen teilen so wie es
uns allen geht
in der hinsicht dass ich natürlich auch
zu hause bin mich an die regeln und die
abstandsregeln und die bewegungs
beschränkungen halte ich bin sicherlich
privilegiert ich bin in berlin nicht in
madrid oder in london oder in porto
brass oder in lagos
also insofern unterscheidet sich dann
auch meine situation vielleicht von der
von vielen anderen
aber natürlich mache ich mir große
sorgen um die auswirkungen dieser
pandemie
sie schreiben in ihrem corona tagebuch
an einer stelle und das hat mich sehr
ins denken gebracht dass sie finden man
spricht jetzt zu früh über das danach da
gibt es diesen satz dass sie sagen es
geht eigentlich jetzt darum wie sich die
gegenwart in etwas verwandeln lässt das
mir gehört bevor wir über dieses danach
sprechen was heißt dass wir sie genau
ja ich glaube dass wir das in dieser
woche speziell noch mal erlebt haben ein
ungeheures füße scharren einen druck
doch möglichst schnell jetzt lockerungen
öffnungen eine rückkehr zu einem danach
zu erreichen ohne dass man ganz sicher
sagen kann dass das schon der richtige
moment dafür wäre ich muss zugeben ich
habe dieselbe sehnsucht wie viele andere
ich möchte auch gerne
meine freiheit zurück ich möchte auch
gerne dass wir wieder arbeiten können
ich möchte auch gerne die sorge um die
ökonomischen auswirkungen von mir haben
aber ich sehe noch nicht dass wir
wirklich in einer situation angekommen
sind in dem man beruhigt sein kann und
ich glaube realistisch wenn ich den
bedingungen zu hören wird es erst in
einem jahr oder gar ende nächsten jahres
an den impfstoff gegen der genau diesen
schutz und damit auch die rückkehr zur
normalität bedeutet und bis dahin müssen
wir versuchen uns ja diese
ausnahmesituation zu eigen zu machen
darin praktiken zu entwickeln die
tragfähig sind und uns nicht verzweifeln
lassen
sie beschreiben auch dass es immer
eigentlich schon historische zäsuren
gegeben hat bei dem die zeitgenossen im
moment schon realisiert haben das ist
jetzt eine solche zäsur
also nicht immer nur im nachhinein
seiner mama schon im moment fühlt sich
das für sie so an glauben die wir
erleben im moment eine historische zäsur
ja eindeutig also ich bin unter 67
geboren ich habe sicherlich wie viele
meiner generation mehrere solcher zu
suchen schon erlebt der fall der mauer
war natürlich eine solche historische
zäsur
der elfte september war auch da habe ich
jetzt eine solche zäsur empfunden da
waren nicht rein ich glaube es war etwas
unglücklich ich wollte mich eigentlich
in new york erholen wollte urlaub machen
von kriegsgebieten und bin ein paar tage
vor dem 11 september in downtown
manhattan gelandet um da eben urlaub zu
verbringen
das war dann misslungene um es
vorsichtig zu sagen also es war ein sehr
sehr dramatisch und lange nachwirkende
wochen dort in der stadt
aber diese situation im moment
wird sie sicherlich als eine solche
historische zäsur nicht nur wahrgenommen
werden sondern ich glaube das ist die
große historische aufgabe mit der wir
als generation die wir ja ansonsten in
europa recht verschont geblieben sind
[Musik]
umgehen müssen wir können immer sagen
natürlich hat auch europa gewalt förmige
konflikte erlebt während der jugoslawien
krieg erlebt natürlich haben wir auch
dramatische wirklich dramatische
ökonomische verwerfungen erlebt wie er
heißt jetzt weniger wie ein nordeuropäer
sondern mehr die im süden aber dies
glaube ich ist eine solche historische
aufgabe für unsere ganze generation und
sie wird auch sicherlich nicht eben
einfach nur ein paar wochen oder ein
paar monaten vorbei sein sondern wir
werden auf jahre hinweg mit dem beben
dieser krise zu tun und diese
historische zäsur besteht im moment eben
wirklich auch in einer gegenwart die wir
noch nicht wirklich erfassen
wittgenstein hat man so schön gesagt ein
philosophisches problem hat die form ich
kenne mich nicht aus insofern ist dieses
sich nicht aus kann natürlich auch ein
anlass uns ins philosophieren ins denken
zu kommen
sie greifen in ihrem tagebuch eine szene
auf die mich sehr beschäftigt hab dich
selber nicht gekannt habe aber danach
geguckt habe sie beschreiben nämlich ein
klavierkonzert der portugiesischen
pianistin maria wir es und sie spielt
ein mozart klavierkonzert ist allerdings
in dieser situation als das orchester zu
spielen beginnt im in der unfassbar
eigenartigen bizarren und schwierigen
situation dass sie fest sie hat ein
anderes konzert vorbereitet sie versucht
dem dirigent zu verstehen zu geben
ich kann das nicht spielen das ist das
falsche konzert aber der lässt nicht
locker wir schauen uns diesem konzert
mitschnitt ganz kurz ein teil davon an
schön dass sie es eingespielt haben
großartiger moment wie ich finde weil
man beim zuschauen den schock
nachvollziehen kann und denkt man würde
spucken würde es einem selber passieren
sie sitzt da hört die ersten takte hört
das ist klavierkonzert d moll und sie
ist auch ein ganz anderes eingestellt
und zieht im ersten moment wie eben bei
einem schock blank
sie glaubt sie kann die situation nicht
überstehen und dirigent riccardo chailly
so in einer mischung von rücksichtslos
und großartig vertrauensvoll und sagte
ihm einfach du kannst dass du hast es
gespielt
wir schaffen das los also lässt sich
überhaupt nicht ein auf ihre
verunsicherung und ich glaube etwas
daran taugt als metapher für die jetzige
situation dass wir als eine generation
die ebensolche form von krisen noch
nicht erlebt hat die im ersten moment
auch sich nackt fühlt weil man gar keine
schutzmantel hat für das was einen da
bedroht oder zu bedrohen scheint und es
eben auch so etwas braucht wie einfach
auch das zutrauen dass man vielleicht
doch zurückgreifen kann auf ein
repertoire das man in anderen zeiten
ausgebildet hat dass es doch techniken
und praktiken und eben verhaltensweisen
gibt die uns miteinander verbinden die
solidarität herstellen die einander
helfen und diese zeit überbrücken helfen
und ich glaube dass wir das in den
vergangenen wochen auch schon
ansatzweise eben erlebt haben dass wir
zwar zunächst schockiert sind aber doch
jetzt merken das ist ja ein repertoire
von leicht auch strukturen aber eben
auch wissens formationen gibt die uns
helfen
jetzt sprechen sie von
diesen wir und auch das ist eine frage
die sie umtreibt schon sehr sehr lange
nämlich wie ist eigentlich zeugenschaft
möglich ist ein sprechen über krise
möglich wenn ich dieses wir vielleicht
sogar nicht gibt und doch jeder eben die
auch für sich spricht gerade das
tagebuch ist ja auch eine sehr
persönliche form und sie tippen auch
immer wieder an wie sie kontakte haben
auf der ganzen welt mit
unterschiedlichsten menschen wie
sprechen wir denn die können wir
gemeinsam sprechen und uns austauschen
werden die situationen sozial gesehen
war dermaßen unterschiedlich sind
ja ich glaube das ist richtig ich glaube
dass schwierige im moment ist dass wir
einerseits konstatieren müssen wir leben
eine globale epidemie wir erleben etwas
das die gesamte welt betrifft und in dem
sinne uns alle als weltgemeinschaft als
humanität betrifft und bedroht und
gleichzeitig etwas das eben asynchron
ist dass immer nur zeitversetzt sich
entwickelt das in dem einen moment in
dem wir glauben aufatmen zu können an
einem bestimmten ort der welt der
schrecken den nächsten ordnung nicht
erreicht hat also dass jede
erleichterung jede beruhigung jede
angstfreiheit voreilig ist im grunde
genommen und eben dass diese vorstellung
dass es uns alle betrifft insofern
falsch ist weil sie natürlich alle
ungleich trifft und die bestehenden
asymmetrien die bestehenden
ungerechtigkeiten die bestehenden
sozialen und ökonomischen und
politischen ungleichheiten nur vertieft
werden in dieser krise insofern ist es
eine ausgesprochen
ambivalente erfahrung einerseits oder
eine disparate erfahrung auch die einen
selber finde ich auch permanent ethisch
politisch verwirrt weil man genau diese
form von
hinwendung zu anderen gegenden das
nachdenken über die lebenswirklichkeit
von anderen regionen oder anderen
menschen nachdenken möchte und sie aber
dauernd ins verhältnis setzen muss zu
den eigenen privilegien der eigenen
situation insofern ist es ein 1 1
einfach handeln glaube ich der
verschiedenen kategorien von wir oder
von pluralität in dem wir denken können
wie ich schon gesagt habe diese idee der
zeugenschaft das ist auch haben sie
wirklich in einem buch auch zum
eigentlichen thema gemacht also diese
idee dass weil dinge sagt bahr sind
sollten wir sie auch sagen im moment
geht es auch ein um uns gemeinsam
verständigen wie wir uns fühlen was wir
tun in dieser krise in dieser
zeugenschaft sind sie aber immer wieder
auch eine sehr politische person und im
moment macht ihnen auch große sorgen wie
europa sich verhält und sie sagen im
moment in dieser krise machen sie sich
sorgen dass europa nur zu einem leeren
etikett werden wird was genau meinen sie
damit was erwarten sie von europarlament
also ich erwarte von europa dass es sich
tatsächlich als gemeinschaft versteht
und auch so handelt dass es nicht nur
einen sonntagsreden lippenbekenntnis ist
von der wertegemeinschaft europas zu
sprechen an die tradition der
menschenrechte und der französischen
revolution zu appellieren aber in den
ersten moment in dem es darauf ankäme
diese vorstellungen von menschenrechten
diese vorstellungen von werten auch
entweder für andere einzusetzen wie für
die geflüchteten auf den griechischen
inseln oder für die von den krisen
besonders betroffenen südlicheren
ländern europas also wenn es darum ginge
diese werte dann auch tatsächlich in
solidarität und praktisch konkrete
solidarität im jetzt zu übersetzen wenn
der plan gezogen wird oder
auf der anderen seite die werte gegen
etwas in anschlag zu bringen und das
heißt wenn wir erleben wie viktor orban
in ungarn der de facto den rechtsstaat
ausgesetzt habe und diese krise und die
pandemie einfach nur instrumentalisiert
für autoritäre ambitionen
dann ist auch das ein moment in dem
europa tatsächlich wirklich reagieren
muss um sagen muss diese sorte von
antidemokratischen verhalten gehört
nicht zu euro und solange das nicht
geschieht ist selbst für jemanden wie
mich die wirklich überzeugte
passionierte dankbare europäerin ist das
einfach nur schamlos eine schwierigkeit
scheint mir ja zu seiner das sind sehr
beschäftigt ist dass man immer man sehr
oft ja von solidarität spricht
solidarität ist ein stichwort was wir
unglaublich viel jetzt gehört haben
vielleicht fast überstrapaziert aber
solidarität hat der idee nach immer
diese vorstellung gehabt dass im zentrum
ein gemeinschaftsgefühl steht ein gefühl
der verbundenheit und was er jetzt aber
sehen ist ja schon so was wie das
plötzlich eigentlich die nationalstaaten
sich wieder auf sich selbst besinnen und
sie schreiben auch wie sie an sich
selbst feststellen mit schrecken
feststellen dass bei diesen ganzen
statistiken die man runterladen kann als
erstes mal gucken wie sind die
sterberaten die opferzahlen im eigenen
land also in der krise
gucken wir auch wieder was passiert bei
uns zu hause und vergessen dieses
gemeinschaftsgefühl auszudehnen
vielleicht erst recht ich will einmal
gern ein schritt noch zurückgehen vor
der selbstkritik über die eigene
degression in so eine nationale
erster verhandlung mit der man da diese
infektionszahlen anschaut und zwar bin
ich nicht ganz sicher ob ich ihnen
zustimmen das die voraussetzung für
solidarität so etwas wie ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl wäre das klingt ja
so als müsste jemand mir ähnlich seien
dann mit ich bereit bin
dies unterstrich also und ich es würde
ich bezweifeln
vielleicht weil ich das ganz kurz
ausführen darf warum ich diese idee habe
also dem dem wort sind nach das stammt
aus dem römischen recht dieses usern
solidum und diese idee der gegenseitigen
haftung für diejenigen die das selbe
besitzen dasselbe beackern und insofern
glaube ich schon oder habe ich das immer
so verstanden dass solidarität viel
damit zu tun hat dass man sich erfährt
als 100 zugehörig und es gibt diesen
wunderbaren zeichnungen suchen wenn man
sich von jean jacques rousseau de mal
gesagt hat das gefühl der
mitmenschlichkeit das gefühl der
zugehörigkeit das verdampft auf distanz
sobald wir es auf distanz ausdehnen
wollen verdampft dieses gefühl und
deswegen würde ich immer sagen global
gesehen brauchen wir vor allem eine idee
der gerechtigkeit denn gerechtigkeit ist
nicht auf ein gemeinschaftsgefühl
angewiesen
ja ich weiß was sie wünschen von dem
begriff der gerechtigkeit aber ich
glaube dass der begriff der solidarität
genauso voraus also identitaire
voraussetzungslos sein könnte und zwar
in dem maße in dem wir einfach ich würde
vielleicht sagen der tradition von levin
us uns menschlichkeit als wechselseitige
verwundbarkeit denken als wechselseitige
verletzbarkeit und wir darin einander
verpflichtet uns fühlen und das selbst
sozusagen nicht
das heraus was sie unterstellt hatten -
sie richtig verstanden habe eben eine
zugehörigkeit zu einer bestimmten form
von gemeinschaft oder eine zugehörige
richtig einer bestimmten form von sich
über eigenschaften oder besitz als
gemeinschaft definierende lebensform und
das ist schon etwas was wir im moment
erleben die wechselseitige
verwundbarkeit dass sich eben in dieser
pandemie zeigt dass globalisierung nicht
nur die mobilität von finanzprodukten
oder eben von gütern oder waren oder von
touristen ist sondern dass sich auch
damit ja eine verwundbarkeit den weg
bahnen kam schon eine region in die
andere
diese verwundbarkeit ist aber global
gesehen eben überhaupt nicht gleich also
wenn man an die flüchtlingslager denkt
auf lesbos wo man befürchtet dass dieses
corona virus ausbrechen könnte oder auch
favelas oder irgendwelche armen vierten
gleichzeitig ist natürlich die tatsache
dass dieses virus jetzt so
weltumspannend vorhanden ist ist vor
allem denjenigen sagen wir mal
zuzurechnen die von der globalisierung
vor allem profitieren nämlich diejenigen
die dauernd hin und her reisen und feste
gefeiert haben in allen kontinenten ja
nicht nur also man muss sagen wenn wir
uns bestimmte länder anschauen ich
glaube das beispiel dass mir jetzt
gegenwärtig ist es ecuador so weit dass
rekonstruierbar ist wir diejenigen waren
dies sozusagen zuerst in eine bestimmte
gegend in ecuador gebracht haben
dann sind das wohl so ist das wohnhaus
angestellt gewesen die glaube ich in
spanien gearbeitet hat und nach hause
gereist ist also es ist nicht so einfach
zuzuschreiben dass es vor allem
sozusagen politische oder ökonomische
eliten gewesen
die das virus verteilt haben wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass ein ganz ganz
großer teil der mobilität der welt eben
durch arbeitsmigration auch entschied
ich auch die chinesen wollen dabei wird
zum beispiel ja die frage ist wie gehen
wir weiter in dieser krise vor wie
werden die auch damit umgehen dass diese
samen wir jetzt mal lockdown situation
so schnell sicher nicht ändern wird es
ihr zwar gelockert aber wir werden noch
sehr lange sehr viel mehr auf uns selber
ein zurückgeworfen sein
sie beschreiben sie eindrücklich die uns
manchmal rituale helfen sie nehmen zum
beispiel bezug auf das buch der erste
mensch von einem primo levi der da
schildert wie er selbst im kz noch dante
verse übersetzt hat für einen
mithäftling und sie selber lassen sich
von einem türkischen freund jeden tag
ein wort zu schicken dass sie dann
auswendig lernen
ihr habt da auch ein buch in dieser
krise jetzt geholfen oder mich
interessiert nämlich vom jugend- schul-
haben vom verschwinden der rituale wo er
schreibt dass die rituale so etwas sind
wie wohnungen in der zeit behausungen
geborgenheit orte in der zeit wenn wir
uns nicht mehr auskennen ist dass wir
sie auch für ja ich glaube dass es
können rituale seien die uns helfen in
solchen zeiten die aus den fugen geraten
sind es können objekte seien dinge die
uns zurückführen an einen ort den wir
verloren haben oder verloren glauben
wenn wir uns die literatur von
überlebenden anschauen oder literatur
von menschen die eben situationen
extremer in richtung erfahren haben
so tauchen unterschiedliche mechanismen
auf die ihnen das überleben erleichtert
haben rituale sind genau eines davon sie
haben das beispiel ergehen primo levi
der mit einem mithäftling in auschwitz
dante übersetzt
es gibt die geschichte von ruth klüger
die beschrieben hat wie sie beim appell
balladen innerlich rezitiert hat um
diese quälend langen appelle durchstehen
zu können also auch etwas was nicht nur
ein ritual ist sondern eben auch etwas
was rhythmus hat ist einem die zeit
diese uferlos scheint wieder taktet und
das was überall in wirklich allen
kontexten allen verschiedenen kulturen
wieder auftaucht ist die anbindung an
freunde also das suchen von mindestens
einer anderen person mit der gemeinsamen
man diese zeit untersteht das ist bei
primo levi sauce bei sehr vielen anderen
auch so bei der ge dem chinesischen
präsidenten der über seine zeit im
untersuchungsgefängnis in china
berichtet hat und ich erlebe es auch an
mir selber also auch das ist etwas das
ich auch suche im moment eben die
freundschaft um vielleicht aber andere
formen der über die freundschaft gerade
leben oder kommunizieren können weil wir
uns noch nicht sehen können wie wir das
gerne möchte frau im kit zum schluss wir
wollten ja eigentlich über die zukunft
sprechen sie haben aber sehr deutlich
gemacht warum sie glauben wir müssen
eben nicht übers danach sprechen bevor
wir nicht diese gegenwart eben wie
erfasst haben diese schwierigkeit des
komplett neuen das geworfen seien sie in
eine situation wie wir sie gesehen haben
bei maria joão pires vielleicht trotzdem
zum schluss gibt es etwas wovon sie
denken das zumindest soll uns hinüber
retten oder das zumindest soll etwas
sein wovon sie glauben damit kann die
dann wirklich neu anfahren
ich hatte gehofft sie würden mich fragen
ob ich von etwas sagen könnte dass es
auf gar keinen fall denn noch haben
möchte
das erst worden eine kurze antwort ich
möchte auf gar keinen fall diese und
schlechte akustik und bildqualität
weiter haben ich freue mich dass ich
irgendwann wieder richtig hören könnte
und das was wir hinüber retten könnten
ist glaube ich in der tat an ein
mindestens dieser moment von das
optionen von innehalten der uns zwingt
unsere wirtschafts von unsere wachstums
obsession unsere tourismus vorstellungen
unsere konsum vorstellungen zu befragen
das glaube ich dieses moment von nicht
einfach weiter so sondern sich auch
kritisch zu befragen das würde ich mir
wünschen dass es hält also anders weiter
ich danke ganz ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch auch wenn es auf distanz war
das nächste mal wieder ein studio vielen
vielen herzlichen dank
ganz herzlichen dank schöne grüße ja
nächste woche spricht ich dort mit endo
anaconda dem kopf der schweizer ben
stiller haas über die tragik des lebens
und seine vision einer besseren welt
und jetzt gleich geht es in der
sternstunde kunst weiter mit der
filmbiografie mister und misses
hitchcock einem film über den berühmten
hits und seine lebenslange partner und
seelenverwandte alba berlin
danke fürs interesse bleiben sie gesund
eine gute zeit bis bald
[Musik]